so the other word I find interesting
from you is in LinkedIn you are put one
word which is Optimist what is that
Optimist mindset means
so I think there's a great
misunderstanding of what optimism and
what an optimist is
um you know I think people think
optimism and blind positivity are the
same thing and they're not blind
positivity everything's good
everything's fine everything's good
which a lot of leaders think they have
to do they think they have to be
positive all the time to keep their team
motivated inspired and the reality is it
actually backfires because when we're
going through stress
we actually we see our leader always
positive always positive we think
there's something wrong with us it
actually backfires optimism is different
um optimism is not naive
optimism is very realistic optimism is
the undying belief that the future is
bright
and we can be in a dark tunnel and say
these are hard times and I do not know
how long we will be here but I do not
know how far away that light is but I
know that if we work together we will
come out of this better than we went in
optimism again is about the future but
it is it is absolutely accepting of
difficulty and stress in the current day